Hey guys! Now I got a lot of questions
on mewing:
Daniel, what's mewing?
Does it really work?
Daniel, please make a video
about mewing! So in this video that's
what I'm gonna talk about.
What is mewing
and does it really work?
I'm gonna give you guys
my honest opinion. So let's not
waste any more time let's get to it
Hey if it's your first time here on my
channel I'm Daniel and welcome to
DLM Model Lifestyle! Subscribe and also click the notification bell so you
won't miss any of the next videos.
Now what is mewing?
no, no, no yeah but no that's not...
the type of mewing that we're talking
about. Mewing is a disciplined oral
posture technique that improves your
facial structure meaning your jaw line
by altering your tongues
resting position so that it rests on the
roof of your mouth with your teeth close
and together and your lips close and
together as well, while breathing through
your nose. It also involves chewing and
swallowing your food the right way so
it's a form of myofunctional therapy
that people do because they want a more
defined jawline because they think it will
make them more attractive. Now the
question is: Does it really work? Some of
you guys are thinking huh this is so
stupid
some of you are thinking wow this this
can actually work this might be actually
very very cool and some of you are thinking
it works we've tried it out already and
it's awesome. Well, what does the evidence say?
First, check out dr. Mike Mew. Yes he's
surname is mew... Mew, mewing... so yeah they
they named the whole mewing thing after
he's surname
He's the guy that started this whole
thing (him and his dad). Well I will add his video for you in the
video description so you can check him
out, but the International Association
for face growth gives many case studies
of children as evidence that it does
work. There's also a study published in the Korean journal of orthodontics in 2004
that says it works. There's also
other research studies published like in
the European Journal of orthodontics in
the Aga Khan university  hospital and other
experts show that mewing does work. Now I personally believe that more research
should be done on all ages not just
mainly on young kids and young adults but
apart from those studies I also did a
little bit more research even on YouTube
with a lot of the videos in the comment
sections below I went to go and read and
see hey is there some people who who
experience this themselves and there
were a lot. There are many many people... Do I believe all of them? No, because people lie, right.
But it is very hard not to
believe so many people that say it does
work. So do I believe that it works? Well
let me answer you in this way: No, not if
you're not gonna do it consistently for
a long time, but if you are disciplined
and if you do it the right way then yeah
I believe that it can work so why not
try it out for yourself and test it and
see firsthand experience if it works for
you or not. Now would I do it? Well, honestly right
now in my life... No, because there are things that I want to focus on more and I want
to spend my time on improving other
areas of my life but I have realized
that I have actually always kept my
tongue unconsciously on the roof of my
mouth. Now did that have an influence on
my jawline? I don't know. Maybe, probably
But I do believe that we should try to
improve ourselves inside and out in a
healthy balanced way, but if we worry too
much about our looks all the time it's
not that healthy. So if you're not happy
with your looks then check out this
video and subscribe to my channel and we will talk soon.
Cheers